okay so let's go there because i gotta
talk to you about this so obviously with
the case of boston dynamics
as you may or may not know
it's
always uh either hard coded or remote
controlled there's no intelligence i
don't know how the current generation of
boston dynamics robots works but uh what
i've been told about the previous ones
was that it's basically all cybernetic
control
which means you still have feedback
mechanisms and so on but it's not uh
deep learning for the most part as it's
currently done it's um for the most part
just identifying a control hierarchy
that is congruent to the limbs that
exist and the parameters that need to be
optimized for the movement of these
limbs and then there is a convergence
progress so it's basically just
regression that you would need to
control this but again i don't know
whether that's true that's just what
i've been told about how they work we
have to separate several
levels of discussion here so the only
thing they do is pretty sophisticated
control no with no machine learning
in order to be uh to maintain balance or
to write itself it's a control problem
in terms of using the actuators to when
it's pushed or when it steps on a thing
that's uneven how to always maintain
balance yes and there's a tricky like
set of heuristics around that but
uh that's the only goal everything you
see boston dynamics doing in terms of
that to us humans is compelling
which is any kind of um higher order
movement like turning uh wiggling its
butt
uh like uh
you know uh
jumping back on its two feet
dancing the dancing is even worse
because dancing is hard coded in it's um
it's choreographed by humans
it's choreography software like there is
no of all that high level movement
there's no
anything that you can call certainly
can't call ai but there's no uh
even like basic heuristics it's all hard
coded in and yet
we humans immediately project
agency onto them which is this is
fascinating so the gap here is uh it
doesn't necessarily have agency well it
has a cybernetic control and the
cybernetic control means you have a
hierarchy of feedback loops that keep
the behavior in certain boundaries so
the robot doesn't fall over and it's
able to perform the movements and the
choreography cannot really happen with
motion capture because the robot would
fall over because the physics of the
robot the weight distribution and so on
is different from the weight
distribution in the human body so if you
were using the directly motion captured
movements of the human body to project
it into this robot it wouldn't work you
can do this with a computer animation it
will look a little bit off but who cares
but
if you want to correct for the physics
you need to basically tell the robot
where it should move its limbs and then
the control algorithm is going to
approximate a solution that makes it
possible within the physics of the robot
and you have to find
the basic solution for making that
happen and there's probably going to be
some regression necessary to uh get the
control architecture to to make these
movements but those two layers are
separate yes the the the thing the
higher level instruction of what how you
should move on where you should move is
that i expect that the control level of
these robots at some level is dumb this
is just the
the physical control movement the motor
architecture but uh it's a relatively
smart motor architecture it's just that
there is no high level deliberation
about what decisions to make necessarily
right but see it doesn't feel like um
free will
no that was not where i was trying to
get to i think that in our own uh
body we have that too so we have a
certain thing that is basically just a
cybernetic control architecture that is
moving our limbs
and
deep learning can help in discovering
such an architecture if you don't have
it in the first place
if you already know your hardware you
can maybe handcraft it
but if you don't know your hardware you
can search for such an architecture and
this work already existed in the
80s and 90s people were starting to
search for control architectures by
motor babbling and so on and just use
reinforcement learning architectures to
discover such a thing
and
now imagine that you have the cybernetic
control architecture already inside of
you and you would extend this a little
bit so you are
seeking out food for instance or rest or
and so on and you get to have a baby at
some point
and
now you add more and more control layers
to this and the system is reverse
engineering its own control architecture
and builds a high level model to
synchronize the pursuit of very
different conflicting goals
and this is how i think you get to
purposes purposes are models of your
goals the goals may be intrinsic as the
result of the different set point
violations that you have hunger and
thirst for very different things and
rest and pain avoidance and so on and
you put all these things together and
eventually you need to come up with a
strategy to synchronize them all
and you don't need
just to do this alone by yourself
because we are state building organisms
we cannot function in the isolation the
way that homo sapiens is set up so our
own behavior only makes sense when you
zoom out very far into a society or even
into ecosystemic intelligence on the
planet and our place
in it so the individual behavior only
makes sense in these larger contexts and
we have a number of priors built into us
so we are behaving as if we are acting
on these high level goals pretty much
right from the start
and eventually in the course of our life
we can reverse engineer the goals that
we are acting on what actually are our
higher level purposes
and the more we understand that the more
our behavior makes sense but this is all
at this point complex stories within
stories that are driving our behavior
yeah i just
don't know how big of a leap it is to
start uh
create a system that's able to tell
stories within stories
like how big of a leap that is from
where currently boston dynamics is
or any robot that's operating in the
physical space
uh that
and that leap might be
big if it requires to solve the hard
problem of consciousness which is
telling a hell of a good story
i suspect that um consciousness itself
is relatively simple what's hard is
perception
and the interface between perception and
reasoning
that's for instance the idea of the
consciousness prior that would be built
into such a system by
joshua bangio
and
what he describes and i think that's
accurate is
that
our own
model of the world can be described
through something like an energy
function the energy function is modeling
the contradictions that exist within the
model at any given point and you try to
minimize these contradictions the
tangents in the model
and to do this you need to sometimes
test things you need to conditionally
disambiguate figure and ground you need
to just distinguish whether this is true
or that is true and so on eventually you
get to an interpretation but you will
need to manually depress a few points in
your model to let it snap into a state
that makes sense and this function that
tries to get the biggest dip in the
energy function in your model according
to joshua bangio is related to
consciousness it's a low dimensional
discrete function that tries to
maximize this dip in the energy function
i yeah
i think i would need to dig into details
because i think the way he uses the word
consciousness is more akin to like
self-awareness like modeling yourself
within the world
as opposed to the subjective experience
the hard problem no it's not even the
self within the world the self is the
agent and you don't need to be aware of
yourself in order to be conscious
the self is just a particular content
that you can have but you don't have to
have right you can be conscious in uh
for instance a dream at night or during
a meditation state but you don't have a
self
right where you're just aware of the
fact that you are aware and what we mean
by consciousness and
the colloquial sense is largely this
reflexive self-awareness
that we become aware of the fact that
you're paying attention
that we are the thing that pays
attention we are the thing that pays
attention right
you